all right guys we'll see you tonight
good Carl check out the trash right yep
and he's gone who's ready for a good day
all right listen up everybody
I'm all ears get it get it what's up
Carl
so the Rainmaker was just on and it made
some pretty fresh mud who wants to go
roll in it
yeah that sounds terrible first off it's
wet and you know how I feel about water
and secondly I don't do outside right
I'm down for a little mud bath if you
can just let me out of this cave
oh sorry buddy no can do no hands I'll
see you when you get back
no no not the mud not the moonlight
let's guys have no idea what they're
missing oh yeah make it rain I've gotta
rinse off a little bit check it out
I gotta figure out how to program that
sprinkler it worked up an appetite all
right everybody
who's hungry it depends what were you
thinking
I'm glad you asked I am starting with
the main course of an empty ish jar of
peanut butter that you can lick if you
have a long enough tongue which I happen
to have
there's an old beef jerky wrapper and an
old tuna can yep mine guys I don't be
cliche here but no carrots okay you know
we don't do this enough
good lunch Carl you know I do what I can
are you sure there's no carrots give it
up bonbon doorbell who wants to get it
no I'm too scared
Diane all right I'll handle this it's
just the box Springer Oh Andy brought a
box
I love boxes and there he goes oh I just
thought of something
who wants to throw a little surprise
party for Doug and Linda when I get home
I'm sure it's no surprise that I would
like to if you could just let me out of
this cage I don't know that I can make
it I'm gonna lay on this table for a
while so probably not gonna be there oh
you're they communica oh boy busy
alright everybody hi gonna figure out
how to reprogram those sprinklers or you
don't have no idea how to reprogram them
no surprise Carl I'll deal with the
trash you handle the mind yeah that
seems fair
I'm so happy you're home and so sorry
about your pants good boy Carl hey Linda
you didn't order a box of broken glass
did you never mind